[Musique]
non mais à disposition comme j'ai dit à
des logiciels
qui permettent vraiment d'accélérer
le cycle de renseignements sur des
images satellites ce qu'on va faire
c'est ton en parlant de détecter des
avions des bateaux des chars et on va
permettre de les compter et d'alerté
quand il ya des positions et des
mouvements anormaux et donc comme ça
l'analyste au lieu d'analyser toute
l'image à la main il va se baser sur ces
traits études il va pouvoir mettre son
savoir faire et son intelligence
tactique pour sortir l'information
pertinente le plus de posséder
ce qu'on va apporter c'est que vraiment
c'est la vitesse de traitement est là le
l'étendue du traitement certains en très
peu de temps on va pouvoir sur des
centaines d'image
détecter des avions des bateaux des
chats reprend il faut plusieurs jours ou
plusieurs semaines à une main pour le
faire
[Musique]
ça va dépendre de l'image en elle-même
mais on arrive à faire des très bons
niveaux de précision pas très loin de
l'humain dont cardon voudrait va
différencier les modèles l'avion entre
un mig 29 mai un sucre 27 par exemple
pour ceux à qui ça parle ou différencier
des chars deux véhicules
deux véhicules blindés classique
aujourd'hui il utilise
opérationnellement c'est ces systèmes
après pour la conduite de leurs
opérations de renseignement ou la
préparation des des opérations de combat
bien entendu nous dise pas exactement ce
qu'ils en font mais voilà c'est que
c'est des logiciels aujourd'hui utilisé
opérationnellement au mystère de l'armée
dans différents pays
[Musique]